l'histoire ne sais pas mais je sais
c'est très marrant un beau jour de
printemps préhistorique financer la wii
ça commence par drop et c'est chiant
pour têtu un homme préhistorique
manquait à l'appel
dans la grotte tout le monde
s'inquiétait et ils le cherchaient re
par monts et par vaux et vallées voilà
j'ai écrit le texte tout seul c'est
moins d'un de ses conflits
bah oui mais jules toge et attendait
et il est là ça va les gars tu étais où
quoi on a cherché partout dans la grotte
au s'inquiéter non mais j'étais allé
faire un truc tout seul c'est bon tout
seul
mettez de mettet d'un vous quoi c'est
complètement irresponsable avec tous les
trucs là les trucs avec les grandes dans
les trucs avec les moyennes dans les
trucs qui font tomber les dents les noms
mais je n'avais pas envie de rester dans
la grotte ça va quoi excuse moi et tu
vois que tu l'avais non je te l'avais
n'ont pas je me casse lorca temps
revient lui saut je sais bien mais je
veux qu'à gloor qu'attend s'il te plaît
par pas mais pourquoi tu sors tout seul
je supporte plus la grotte là c'est ça
me tue tu trouves pas que ça son fort à
l'intérieur
forget en ramenant est forte et un fort
guam tu peux définir fort mauvais ça
sent mauvais nan faut être plus précis
parce que là je ne comprends pas oizo
mauvais genre lauder fait que quand tu
commences à manger à quelque chose et n
a pas envie de le finir tellement ça non
ça m'arrive jamais ça mais après oui
c'est vrai quelle odeur désagréable
surtout depuis que steve y dort là
depuis un mois ça sont mais en plus de
steve
non je vois pas moi je pense ça vient du
caca plus bas évidemment mais ça après
on est obligé oui je dis pas qu'il faut
s'arrêter je dis qu'il faut s'arrêter
dans la grotte
tu vois ouais faudrait l'éloigner de
nous par exemple imagine imagine en
avant un truc tu mets ton caca deux ans
tu appuies sur quelque chose où tu tires
et ton caca il disparaît ouais ça ça
serait super et on pourrait appeler ça
la roue ou le feu oiseaux
nous nous tenons ce nous tue c'est un
pote à moi ok le benzène trop long ouais
c'est vrai bon on retrouvera déjà
fabriquant un truc où on fait
disparaître le caca en tirant ou en
poussant oui les 2 sont possibles mais
en même temps en vente et ça c'est pas
facile hein déjà techniquement je sais
même pas parler on se comprend par des
gestes et des cris sinon on fait un trou
au fond de la grotte
ah bah voilà et on appelle ça la roue ou
la poudre excellent merci ou d'uranium
enrichi et on fera tous kaka dans
l'uranium enrichi à un problème pourquoi
si deux personnes ont enlevé en même
temps et pains céréales ont dit ils
doivent se battre à mort et le survivant
il peut aller à l'uranium enrichi où il
y en a un qui se retient et qui attend
son tour assez horrible se retenir et a
pas de coeur non le combat à mort c'est
plus simple moi ça me va je trouve ça
bien plus que génial on note tout ça
avec plaisir mais je sais pas noté je
sais pas écrire je sais pas ce qu'ils
écrire signifie moi non plus alors on
retient tous à deux têtes et on va le
dire aux autres voilà aucune chance
ouais moi pareil j'ai pas de mémoire
bon eh ben on aura bien passer le temps
quand même encore carrément moi je
trouve et c'est ainsi que pas grand
chose s'est passé mais on a bien passer
le temps quand même
en tout cas d'après des chaussettes
oiseaux à acheter taggage ok ça vaut